über diese bilder und den gestrigen tag
wollen wir jetzt sprechen mit mike
mohring cdu chef von thüringen herzlich
willkommen und guten morgen und die
erste frage an sie haben gerade eben die
bilder nochmal gesehen was empfinden sie
wenn sie das sehen also einen schönen
guten morgen zu ihm nach berlin
die bilder gestern sind erschütternd
unfassbare mental ist es schlicht ein
zustand den wir noch nie erlebt haben
dass bürger versuchen ein
parlamentarisches gebäude zu stürmen und
ich bin wie wolf der polizei sehr
dankbar diesen wenigen drei
polizeibeamten die sich offenbar auch
raichs bürgern entgegen gestellt haben
und das parlament verteidigt haben das
war wichtig es war ein ganz starkes
zeichen aber es zeigt ihm auch das
wenige offenbar für viele tausende
plötzlich so verstörende bilder
organisieren können und man sich fragt
was mischt sich dabei so neu corona demo
zusammen der im senat hatte er gestern
eine durchaus positive bilanz gezogen
dennoch werden jetzt auch stimmen laut
die das einsatzkonzept der polizei
kritisieren wie beurteilen sie das
also für mich ist ganz klar die das
verbot der demo im vorfeld das war ein
kardinalfehler ich bin dabei wolfgang
bosbach der eine ursache darin sieht
dass ich daran etwas verstärkt hat
unsere versammlungsfreiheit ist ein
hohes gut unserer freiheitlich-
demokratische gesellschaft muss es und
tut es ja auch in der trägt auch
unterschiedlichste meinung auch wenn sie
noch so schräg sind
ich kann corona demos nichts abgewinnen
und dennoch haben die bürgerinnen und
bürger ein recht auch ihre meinung zu
sagen aber und das ist entscheiden der
versammlungsfreiheit ist nicht
grenzenlos und mit einem auflagen
gemacht werden zu einer demo die ja auch
dort gemacht werden die nicht
eingehalten werden beim wunsch schutz
nicht getragen wird bei abstand nicht
eingehalten wird weil dann geht auch die
versammlungsfreiheit eine grenze und
dann kann auch diese versammlung die
vorher eben auch angemeldet und
genehmigt war dann auch aufgelöst werden
und wenn dagegen widerstand ist dann
muss sich der staat mit seinem
rechtlichen konsequenzen auch
durchsetzen bei das stärkt erst unseren
rechtsstaat dass man seine rechte
geltend machen kann dass man seine
meinung sagen kann aber eben auch dass
man sich selbst als recht hält und
einerseits alles infrage zu stellen
selbst die rechtlichen grundlagen nicht
anmerken das funktioniert in unserer
freiheitlichen demokratie nicht ja jetzt
auch gestern die bilder vom reichstag
das zentrum das symbol unserer
demokratie
wie sollte man ihrer ansicht nach gegen
die menschen vorgehen die gestern
versucht haben dieses gebäude zu stürmen
als zuallererst glaube ich muss man mal
diesen drei polizeibeamten großen dank
aussprechen und die auch noch mal ein
besonderer weise würdigen klar sie haben
ihren dienst gemacht aber ist kein
alltäglicher einsatz gewesen den wir
gestern gesehen haben und deswegen gilt
stellvertretend für tausende
polizeibeamtinnen und -beamten die jeden
tag ein kopf hinhalten für unsere
sicherheit besonderen dank und
stellvertretend diesen drei von beck für
alle die das jeden tag tun egal ob sie
bei der feuerwehr sind oder im
rettungsdienst oder eben auch bei der
polizei beim bund oder bei den ländern
und dann muss klar sein dass die die da
offensichtlich randaliert haben
dieter besonders aggressiv gewesen sind
dass die auch sofort jetzt die folgen
sehen und auch bestraft werden und da
muss sozusagen immer auf die tat auch
die strafe auf dem fuß folgen damit sie
sagen auch die konsequenz angenommen
wird
aber eben auch damit man sieht dieser
dieser teil der den reichstag stürmen
wollte sind aber nicht die tausenden die
sich vielleicht auch sorgen machen jeden
tag wie man mit den maßnahmen corona
umgehen muss für mich ist ganz klar das
was jens spahn und was angela merkel an
anderen der bundesregierung leisten ist
in dieser phase total wichtig und
richtig die skeptisch sind die muss man
auch aufklären jeden tag das hat
wolfgang bosbach gesagt aber die das
alles infrage stellen
die unsere demokratie in frage stellen
die müssen wissen dass hat alles seine
grenzen
mike mohring cdu chef von thüringen
vielen herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch
denn einen schönen sonntag dankeschön